hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing something
very different from the Channel's normal
content and that is the controversial
topic of Hermione Granger's ethnicity
Hermione Jean Granger was a muggleborn
witch born on September 19
1979 while not boarding at Hogwarts
School she resided at eight heathgate
Hampstead Garden suburb London with her
parents Mr and Mrs Granger a pair of
lovely muggle dentists Hermione had
bright brown eyes lots of bushy brown
hair once described as a long Mane of
brown hair and as a child supported
particularly large front teeth while not
in her Hogwarts robe she was known to
dress quite casually and she is famous
for her rather bossy voice that turns
quite shrill in moments of anger but
perhaps the most notable characteristics
of Hermione Granger are that she is
extremely intelligent and very hard
working these are facts however the one
thing about her character that's always
been left a little more ambiguous is her
ethnicity this subject has garnered a
considerable amount of attention in more
recent years and is a topic of
contention among Harry Potter fans so
what is Hermione Granger's ethnicity to
some the obvious answer is that Hermione
is Caucasian after all that's how she
was portrayed in the films Emma Watson
who played Hermione is white it's as
simple as that however the Harry Potter
films certainly aren't the only visual
representations of Harry Potter
characters beyond the books nor are they
necessarily the standard in the cursed
child for example Hermione Granger is
played by a black actress named Noma
dumasweni it's also worth highlighting
that there are numerous other examples
of racial ambiguity among characters in
the Harry Potter series the best example
is lavender Brown a fellow Gryffindor
student that is known for developing a
fleeting romance with her beloved 1-1 in
the Chamber of Secrets lavender Brown is
played by black actress Kathleen Cawley
following that she's played by another
black actress Jennifer Smith who takes
on the role in The Prisoner of Azkaban
however by the time Half Blood Prince
came out the role of lavender Brown had
been taken over by Caucasian actress
Jessie cave Warner Bros reasoning for
this is that by the time the sixth film
came out it was time for lavender's
character to really Blossom she went
from background character to front and
center and so they decided they wanted a
more established actress in the role
because the previous portrayals of
lavender were so trivial in comparison
it's likely that they never properly
assessed the acting abilities of Corley
or Smith it's likely that the casting
director just assigned the name Lavender
Brown to the two previous actresses to
keep track of the minor roles as the
films progressed another example is Dean
Thomas a Gryffindor student who's
described as having dark skin and black
hair he is said to have grown up in
London but the subject of his ethnicity
is a bit confusing in the US version of
the Philosopher's Stone it specified
that he's black but this piece of
information is not included in the
original UK version I think that this
perfectly highlights the lack of
emphasis and ambiguity surrounding race
in Harry Potter but provided that
Hermione's ethnicity is so polarizing
with each sign vehemently defending
their own dance I want to dig deeper and
try to uncover some semblance of an
answer here it's Hermione white or black
one of the main arguments for Hermione
being white stems from a quote in the
Prisoner of Azkaban
the footsteps stopped Harry heaved on
the Rope Buckbeak snapped his beak and
walked a little faster Hermione's white
face was sticking out from behind a tree
Harry she mouthed the focus here is on
Hermione's white face which out of
context may be interpreted as a
Caucasian or white face but personally I
think it's quite obvious that the
adjective white is being used here to
describe Hermione in a state of fear and
is in no way any sort of a reference to
her skin color referencing her skin
color in this context would be
completely out of place and unnecessary
and I think that white face is just used
to emphasize the tension of the moment
and how her skin would have turned pale
from Fear again this is just an
expression another passage from the
books that could be interpreted as
referencing Hermione's skin color comes
from chapter 4 of The Prisoner of
Azkaban there they were both of them
sitting outside Florian fortescue's ice
cream parlor Ron looking incredibly
freckly Hermione very Brown both waving
frantically at him here Hermione is
described as very brown but I think it's
quite obvious at least to me that this
passage merely refers to the fact that
Hermione had gotten a tan over the
course of the summer JK Rowling is quite
clearly at least to me describing the
effects of a sunny summer on the pair
with Ron developing freckles and
Hermione developing a tan
there are also a couple of passages
across the books that reference
Hermione's cheeks going pink but again
it's extremely unlikely that this is any
sort of an attempt at describing
Hermione's skin color it's much more
likely that Hermione going pink simply
refers to her blushing an involuntary
reddening of the face due to
embarrassment or stress given the nature
of Hermione's character it's not
surprising that certain situations would
cause her to blush another argument for
Hermione's ethnicity is that her hair is
described as bushy potentially alluding
to afro-textured hair with that said
however I do not personally view bushy
as an adjective that is exclusive to the
hair of any particular racial group I
think that all sorts of people can have
bushy hair before we dive in any further
I've got to say this the supporting
evidence for both sides of this argument
are pretty dismal given that a passage
pointing to Hermione's white face and an
attempt at conflating bushy hair with
rice are the primary drivers behind each
side's argument I'd say we're in rough
shape so where does that leave us well
unfortunately it leaves us with a whole
bunch of contradictions if we dive in
deeper another one of the arguments for
Hermione being Caucasian is that JK
Rowling based Hermione off of herself in
this sense the character of Hermione was
built off of an autobiographical
framework but here's the thing yes
Hermione was based off of JK but not to
the extent that has been extrapolated by
some readers the following quote clears
this up somewhat I did not set out to
make Hermione like me but she is a bit
like me she's an exaggeration of how I
was when I was younger and just because
Hermione's personality is reminiscent of
rolling herself it absolutely does not
mean that she is somehow automatically
Caucasian Hermione is a bit like JK and
certainly not an extension of her that
his identical in every way piecing
together all of these sources of
information at our disposal passages
from the books book covers actor
portrayals quotes from Rolling here at
the most compelling Arguments for
Hermione being Caucasian the first
argument is that rolling when discussing
Hermione's casting once explained that
her only complaint was that Emma Watson
was too pretty to be Hermione and that
otherwise she was perfect this could
imply that a Caucasian actress is what
Rowling had in mind for Hermione all
along the next piece of evidence
supporting that Hermione is Caucasian
comes from an illustration published on
JK Rowling's website in 2004 this
illustration drawn by Rolling herself
depicts an early draft the midnight
Jewel chapter where we see Neville Ron
Harry Hermione and Gary later renamed to
Dean Thomas in this illustration Dean
clearly has darker skin than the rest of
them including Hermione I think we can
reasonably deduce this is what Rowling
had originally envisioned when she was
first inventing the characters and
provided that all of the other
characters from this illustration
somewhat matched the actor that was
eventually assigned to play them it
could suggest that Hermione was indeed
meant to be Caucasian however all of
this was contradicted by a tweet that
Rowling published in 2015. Canon brown
eyes frizzy hair and very clever white
skin was never specified Rowling loves
black Hermione given that book Canon is
up to the discretion of the author and
that Rowling herself has left this very
ambiguous the final verdict on
Hermione's ethnicity is that it is
entirely up to reader interpretation and
I think that in many ways this was
always her intention by leaving
descriptions of characters so ambiguous
it heightens the ability of every one of
her readers to relate to them entirely
in their own way she is described as
having brown eyes and bushy hair but
beyond that the visual for Hermione is
left entirely up to each reader's
interpretation if you were to give this
vague criteria to 1 000 artists you'd
end up with 1000 completely different
outcomes the change in Hermione skin
color was from my perspective not an
attempt at diversifying the series but
instead a nod to the fact that it
doesn't really matter and that's it for
this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember
differences of habit and language are
nothing at all if our aims are identical
and our hearts are open
foreign